Hey hi Messner Miller and you are now
entering Lashley editor flash league
starting today we'll be traversing the
supersonic world of the flash to see how
a normal guy like Barry Allen managed to
become the fastest human earner and what
he decided to do about it it's really
cool you guys ready to do battle and
stuff I've never done battle I just
pushed some people
[Music]
I'll take that as a yes what the ring
[Music]
good morning after the death of Superman
violence acts of war and terrorism are
all on the rise I had a dream it was the
end of the world
I think it's something more something
darker
we're asking people we'd unknown to risk
their lives strong man and strong us
alone never heard that it's not saying
that's the opposite of what the saying
is
divided we are not enough
[Music]
or Superman
[Music]
[Applause]
I made him a promise
why I brought you together
ride ain't over yet man
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh awesome as a bad signal that's your
oh sorry
it's your signal that means we have to
go now yeah I sort of mean it's so cool
you